-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian and actor whose latest
special, "Mohammed in Texas," is
available on Netflix.
Please welcome to the show
Mo Amer, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome. How are you?
-I'm great.
-This is very exciting.
Your special takes place --
You shoot it in Texas.
You grew up in Texas,
but you left Kuwait for Texas.
-Correct.
-That must have been a trip,
as a kid.
-We left a big part of it.
We didn't just, like,
voluntarily leave.
-Yeah.
-Because of the Gulf War.
-Yes.
-Part one.
[ Laughter ]
And we ended up
in Houston, Texas.
-How old were you at the time?
[ Cheers ]
-What's up, H-Town?
People made it.
Apparently, other people
fleeing Texas as well.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So how old were you
when that happened?
-I was nine.
-Okay, and so how was Texas?
It must have been
a culture shock.
-It was, definitely.
My family did no research
when we moved to Houston.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-I went to a private British
English school in Kuwait
and ended up in Houston in
a gang-riddled neighborhood.
[ Laughter ]
And I was caught in between
a gang battle.
Mexicans were trying to
recruit me
because they thought
I was Mexican,
and black gangs wanted to
beat me up
because they thought
I was Mexican.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be walking down the street
and I see the Mexican gangs
hanging out, and they were like,
"Hey, vato.
You walk by here every day.
You don't say nothing,
don't do nothing.
What? You ashamed of
your own peoples, bro?"
[ Laughter ]
"You ashamed of your own
la raza, your familia, bro?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Nah, man,
my name is Mohammed."
They're like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
They're like, "For real, bro?
You look exactly like
my cousin Hector!
No way, bro!"
[ Laughter ]
-And then was it important for
you to shoot this special there?
-Absolutely, it was
so important.
I mean, Houston is the city that
raised me and embraced me
and showed me so much love.
It was a big, big part of
my life, and I think Houston
doesn't get the flowers
that it deserves.
So that's why I decided
to shoot it there.
-That's a really nice way
to show some gratitude
to your hometown,
your adopted hometown.
You did a film with The Rock,
and actually,
The Rock, via video, opens this
up for you,
opens up your special.
How is it working with The Rock?
-It was good. He was trying to
get bigger for the movie.
We did the "Black Adam" movie,
and he was just so great, man.
He was really gracious.
And like you said,
he introduced me for my special,
which was so cool.
But, you know, he's just
a fun guy, and I didn't know
how much fun he was,
you know what I mean?
Like, you're just on
a superhero set,
and no way you can prepare
for that.
And he just walks on,
and he's the only one that
didn't need, like, muscle pants.
He just walks on
just wearing spandex.
And everybody is calling him
different names like,
"What's up, Rock?"
"What's up, D.J.?"
"Hey, Dwayne."
And I walked up to him like,
"Hey, man, what do I call you?"
He goes, "Daddy."
I was like --
[ Laughter ]
I just looked at him.
I was like, "Faja?"
[ Laughter ]
"Is that you, faja?"
I'd get adopted by him,
you know what I mean?
-I mean, that's the jackpot.
-Yeah, it would be cheat meals
every day, bro.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard a story that you had
a English teacher who was aware
that you wanted to be up
on stage doing comedy
and let you use the room
for comedy in return
for doing some more
scholarly stuff.
-Yeah, exactly. It was a thing.
Like, my dad died when I was 14,
and I was just skipping class.
I was basically living like
"Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
I was, like, on third base
watching the Astros.
I was like 14. I had no business
being there, you know?
And she just was so proactive
and amazing.
She goes, "Don't you want to be
a comedian?
Don't you want to graduate
high school?
How would your father feel
if you don't graduate?"
I'm like, "That's a cold shot,
Mrs. Reed!"
You know?
[ Laughs ]
"Yeah, I do."
And she goes, "Well, if you go
up in front of the class
and recite Shakespeare,
I'll give you extra credit,
and I'll let you do stand-up
every Friday."
And I was like, "That's a hell
of a bargain."
I was like, "Do I have to do it?
Like, can I just do it
comically?"
She goes, "You can do it any way
you want."
So I just went up right in front
of the class.
I was like -- [Overdramatically]
"To be or not to be.
'Tis is the question."
You know what I mean?
-I have to ask, did you ever
have a bad set
with your material
in front of the class?
-I did. I did. Science class.
It was a rough one.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-The labs were going,
you know what I mean?
Kids were trying not to burn
themselves.
I'm trying to do Chris Farley
impressions in front of them.
[ As Chris Farley ]
"You're going nowhere!"
You know, like --
[ Laughter ]
It just didn't work out.
-How does your family --
I mean, they must be so proud of
you now.
How do they feel when they when
they get to see you
doing stand-up?
-Oh, they think I'm an engineer.
-Oh, okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-Will this be the first they --
-This is -- I'm sorry, Mom.
[ Laughter ]
What a failure I am.
No, they're really -- you know,
it's an indigenous art form
to America, stand-up comedy,
right?
It's like stand-up,
hip-hop, and jazz.
And so I never knew it existed.
So my family, in turn, didn't
really understand
what was happening, particularly
my mother, and yeah, man.
She's very proud.
She's very, very proud, yeah.
I met Steve Harvey,
and that was, like,
the biggest accomplishment.
Even though I toured with
Chappelle for like 10 years.
You know, Jon Stewart.
I've worked with The Rock
and everything else.
Steve Harvey.
That's it, you know what I mean?
It was like, my mom watches
game shows, that's it.
"Meeting Steve Harvey, ohh!
You're really making it now."
-Well, he's worldwide.
Steve Harvey is really
a worldwide star.
Hey, Mo, really great
to meet you.
Congrats on the special.
-Thank you so much.
-Thank you for coming out
tonight.
You guys, that's Mo Amer,
everybody!
"Mohammed in Texas,"
streaming now on Netflix.